thanks and good morning for the last two
years the tea medline had has been
building a new kind of role-playing
experience fable legends is a bold and
innovative adventure and I'm proud to
share it with you here today welcome to
a place of magic fairy tale and myth
this is where we can discover the
stories and characters of Albion this is
bright Lodge the social heart of fable
legends and your home in the game
say hello to Stirling he's a classic
fable character hangs in the balance
and to hero brave noble capable of self
narration in this growing town you and
your friends fine to begin your quests
you'll also encounter many of the heroes
you'll team up with here are just a few
of them winter a hero of will somewhere
out there is treasure adventure and a
world of things better than standing
right here Rock I hear a skill
all right fancy-pants and Inga a hero of
strength well don't hang about polishing
your Koch khun's we've got questing to
do right let's see what so they're in
this chapter a fable legends story the
heroes and turned old and over grew in
ruin in order to recover an ancient
artifact
while humanity and its champions venture
into untamed lands in primeval forests
the natural world prepares to strike
back magical beasts monsters and even
nastier creatures are marshalling their
forces to defeat those who dare trespass
into their realm we get in we get out
swift and smooth family motto and
lifestyle choice old challenge own up
Stella
all right boys and girls this is where
to get serious this quest shall lead
into honor glory and Oh treasure I'll be
taking this only there have been more of
them ha got you wouldn't scratch your
Wordle we got away with that one our
vision is for more than just a
cooperative fable we want to create an
experience unique in multiplayer gaming
something innovative and something
dramatic we needed a new challenge for
you our players in fable legends you can
be the villain the villain player in
fable Legends brings a whole new
perspective to the game controlling the
world from above like a malevolent God
every creature every trap and every
spell you've seen so far every challenge
our heroes are about to face the villain
orchestrates at all if you're the
villain it's your job to do the worst
you decide how where and who to target
with your many evil powers and tricks
how does our story end the outcome of
each of your adventures depends on
what's stronger
is it the bravery and teamwork of the
four heroes or the skill and dastardly
cunning of the village
we're almost there stick with it you
idiot look I ain't nothing to you bro
Roy
Stevie noogie how did we know smell
watch yourselves
Olga
I think I chose the wrong underwear for
this one
the bigger they are the easier the
target
now I've got you one of the beggars oh
crap
on behalf of the team at Lionhead it's
been my pleasure to share this first
look into fable legends our multiplayer
beta will begin this fall to sign up and
learn more visit fable legends comm join
us in our magical world and play as a
part of a team of heroes or mastermind
the game as the evil villain the choice
is yours